all right today we're going to start by
looking at how many
of his hundred day promises joe biden
has accomplished as president either
partially
or fully and i think it makes sense to
say at the outset
that we will evaluate whether he did the
things he promised to do
the the question of whether he promised
to do the right things
is a separate one so like as an example
if joe biden promised to
cancel ten thousand dollars in student
debt and did it but you think he should
have
done 50 000 these are two different
questions did he promise the right thing
and did he achieve the thing that he
promised but let's just
jump right into it starting with climate
the uh
npr and the ap have really good trackers
on this and i encourage you to check out
i'm looking at the associated press
tracker and it's very very good so on
climate
four promises joe biden has kept he has
taken executive action to reduce
greenhouse gas emissions he did rejoin
the paris climate accord
he supported an amendment to the
montreal protocol to curb
uh hfcs and he has convened a world
climate summit which recently took place
he did
those four things that he promised he
has not yet done
infrastructure that will sort of be
uh done in a way that takes into account
the big picture climate picture uh he he
just hasn't done infrastructure yet
he has not taken steps to conserve
conserve 30 percent of u.s lands and
waters by 2030
and he has not received emission
reductions commitments from the shipping
and
aviation industry on the economy joe
biden has accomplished
four of his five promises he has
extended a pause on student loan
payments
he did pandemic relief 1.9 trillion
he did review the u.s supply chain for
vulnerabilities in key sectors
those have been identified he has taken
steps to strengthen buy american
measures
and he has not yet increased the
corporate tax rate so four out of five
on economy and taxes now you might be
saying well hold on he made other
promises economically yes but they were
not
hundred day promises we're looking at
hundred-day promises
uh on government functioning he has done
three of four
he tightened ethics rules he insulated
the justice department from politics
he eased federal unionization
restrictions he did not
restore rules that were weakened by
donald trump
on gun control he's really done nothing
yet
he promised to send congress a gun
control bill
it's sort of partially been met but it's
not been completed
he uh promised to reauthorize the
violence against women act
it's on its way but it has not yet been
done
um commissioning an attorney general
report to restructure agencies to
enforce gun laws
he's gotten merrick garland started on
it
but it's not yet been done um and
uh he also promised an fbi report on how
to tighten gun purchase
background check check loopholes has not
been done
healthcare he made eight promises for
his first hundred days and he's done
five
he did do a mask mandate on federal
property
he rejoined the world health
organization he
set up a hundred mass vaccination
centers he vaccinated 100 million
americans actually 200 million and he
did deploy
mobile vaccination clinics he has not
expanded healthcare access
in a meaningful way yet uh and he has
not
outlined new pandemic measures for
future pandemics that's been requested
it's sort of you could say in
process and he has not yet reopened most
elementary and middle schools
on housing he said he would pause
evictions and foreclosures and he did
and there were some other strategic
things like
uh coming up with a strategy to make
housing a right that's not yet been done
so he did do one thing on housing
immigration is a tough one there were a
lot of immigration promises made in fact
17
many have not been accomplished the
naturalization process hasn't been
streamlined um
increases to the amount of refugees have
not taken place but
he did send congress an immigration bill
which he promised to do
he did revise deportation criteria
although many people would say yeah they
were revised but it's not nearly enough
he did take steps to re reunite
separated migrant families
he did end the travel ban he did stop
deportations
for certain groups and with a lot of
these with the immigration stuff the
devil's really in the details where
the promise is very open-ended
so you and i would look at what's going
on with deportations and we would say
there's still a ton of them going on the
promise was to stop deportations
for certain groups and he did sign a
memo
on that but we i don't feel it's nearly
enough
he stopped border wall construction uh
reversed the public charge rule for
immigrants and and then there's a whole
bunch of other stuff that is sort of
arguably in progress he's asked for it
hasn't really
happened uh he promised to freeze
deportations for a hundred days remember
he did it but then it was blocked by a
judge
on inequality basically nothing has yet
been done
he made 12 promises the only one that's
been accomplished
is creating a uh a working group a union
issues working group
to deliver a plan on increasing union
membership that's been done
all the other stuff hasn't you know
addressing systemic racism in u.s
institutions
signing the equality act uh appointing a
commission to study sexual assault in
the military these are things that joe
biden has
said he wants done while being president
so so they're marked as in
process they have not yet been done
um and then on national security joe
biden promised to rejoin the iran
nuclear deal
um he has he has started that process it
has not happened so
how do you grade his promises i mean
you know the the thing that's tough
about this is a lot of these promises we
all knew were never going to happen
much like with trump we knew where trump
was never going to build a wall across
the entire border and get mexico to pay
for it in his first four years
this was never gonna happen and he
failed and so
it was a promise he failed to deliver on
trump was never going to pay off the
national debt in four years
and of course he blew it up actually uh
joe biden's promises were more
reasonable but some were still clearly
not going to happen so if we just grade
him on a percentage basis
it's like a c um if we grade him based
on
his intentions via things he signed
orders on
but obviously take longer than 100 days
and we account for all of the realities
it's probably like a b-plus
but but with all of these things the
questions
really are how do we interpret
his intention to do something versus the
practicality
when you understand that there are other
players involved
you're going to have to tell me how to
evaluate that and ultimately voters are
going to decide
some great things done and compared to
many other presidents
this has been one of the most productive
first hundred days compared to all the
things he promised
if you just you don't do a curve of any
kind that accounts for
practical difficulties it's like he's
done kind of you know half the stuff
or something like that so let me know
your thoughts and how we should be
evaluating it
one of our sponsors is privacy.com
they're giving you five dollars when you
sign up for their completely
free service at privacy.com
pacman i've been using privacy for a
little over a year now you've heard me
talk about it before
it's a lifesaver and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something online or on
the phone
instead of actually using your real
credit card number the privacy app and
the browser plug-in
let you give each company a randomized
virtual credit card number that you
create out of thin air it'll even
autofill the card number with one click
and the payment is taken out of your
checking account
without the merchant ever knowing your
real information so this allows you to
keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create
up to 12 of these virtual credit cards a
month you can set spending limits you
can freeze them
you can delete them anytime you want so
when you do this
it means you're not going to be charged
when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number
right after using it which for instance
i love using free trials because i know
i won't be charged when the trial is
over if i use a virtual credit card
number
you're keeping your identity private by
not telling companies who you are
you're keeping your bank or credit card
info protected
against data breaches and identity theft
and it's free
and like i said you'll get five dollars
to spend when you sign up
at privacy.com pacman